als der rechtsextremist brücke zum
parteitag kommt hat er sich viel
vorgenommen die nächste häutung der art
wie beim häuten der zwiebel seit
anbeginn der afg geschichte schalen
schicht um schicht abgetragen von der
euro-kritischen professoren partei eines
bernd lucke über die rechtspopulistische
wutbürger afd einer frauke petry bis zum
lange radikal zündelnden und zu spät
löschenden jörg morgen immer hatte röcke
maßgeblich mit geschält nun auf dem
parteitag in riesa hatte er ein
zweckbündnis geformt um das läuten herbe
die wolkenschicht endgültig abzutragen
dieser neue bundesvorstand entspricht
bisher vollständig meinem geschmack der
reihe nach dem geschmack zunächst das
neue führungsduo kino copala und alice
weidl als doppelspitze die sich gegen
das selbsternannte gemäßigtere lager
durchsetzen
gegenkandidaten wie norbert kleinwächter
am ende chancenlos gold beginnt der
aufbruch ich schaue nicht mehr zurück
was gewesen ist was war die ära leuten
ist mit dem heutigen tag beendet
beendet und genüsslich nachgetreten
[Musik]
hat vor einer woche in einer groß
angekündigten pressekonferenz seinen
beitritt zur katholischen mini partei
zentrum erklärt
er hat dafür extra einen kostspieligen
saal in der bundespressekonferenz in
berlin gebucht und tatsächlich hätte für
dieses trauerspiel ein beichtstuhl in
einer friedhofskapelle
aufgereiht
die ära meuten wird hier lückenlos
ausradiert es ist der tag der abrechnung
die radikalen hatten rache geschworen
als 91 den rechtsextrem andreas kalbitz
aus der partei war keiner von denen die
damals mit gestimmt haben ist mehr dabei
abgewählt oder hingeschmissen nach einer
wütenden auseinandersetzung ein lager
endgültig immer zeit
das ist tatsächlich so dass die
ankündigung von tino copala dass man
alle strömungen im bundesvorstand
abbilden wollen die ich erfreut zur
kenntnis genommen hatte in keiner weise
umgesetzt ist ich glaube mit
konzentration auf inhalte mit dem
freundlichen auftreten mit image wechsel
würden nur besser dastehen ich habe das
jahrelang in die hand versucht ich habe
es extern versucht man wollte nicht
aufhören und irgendwann muss man sagen
wir wollten nicht stattdessen werden
reihenweise radikale in den vorstand
gewählt die für einen enthemmten kurs
stehen radikal und mitunter
intellektuell ausgedehnt sagte nar
schwert niemals ein freundlicher fort
das heißt wenn wir wenn wir nicht
begeistert sind können wir auch nicht
begeistert also lasst uns nicht die
stadt sagten erste sein sondern lasst
uns fröhlich geführt zu werden wenn ihr
so wollt wir sind die einzige echte
opposition also lasst sie uns weiter
jagen weil wir deutschland nicht den
deutschland kassen überlassen
teilweise wunschkandidaten teilweise von
kaka flügel aufgezwungen das neue team
von kuba und weil er fährt übrigens das
schlechteste ergebnis der af die
geschichte ein knapp über 50% strauchelt
und kann sich nur gerade so halten
status duldung sie bekommen deutlich
mehr zwei drittel etwa und doch starten
beide mit hypotheken ins neue amt als
spitzenkandidaten du four und
fraktionschefs nach der bundestagswahl
prägten sie zuletzt das bild einer
partei im niedergang reihenweise
verluste bei wahlen in bund und ländern
mit peinlichen wissenslücken pannen und
mitunter vulgären ausrastern
[Applaus]
dass sich weil oft nicht im griff hat
wird auch hier auf dem parteitag wieder
deutlich die frau kollegin dr weide hat
einen delegierten aus baden württemberg
zweimal die geste mit dem finger an die
stirn klopfen gezeigt du spinnst so
etwas ist eines bundes sprechers
unwürdig die stimmung am tag eins der
neuen chefin die neue parteispitze
getriebene dass die partei rote linien
zum braunen mehrheitlich überwinden will
zeigt sich auf dem parteitag etwa beim
gewollten schulterschluss mit den so
genannten verein zentrum automobil den
weigel getreue gegen höcke verhindern
wollten wir wollen uns allen ernstes
hier in verbindung gegeben mit solchen
leuten die jetzt auch noch mit npd neue
werte und so weiter auf die straße gehen
wir sind doch die große starke afd wir
haben das doch nicht nötig liebe freunde
die kulturelle hegemonie werden wir
niemals nur den parlamentarischen weg
erreichen wir brauchen dieses vorfeld
ohne dieses vorfeld sind wir nichts und
werde nicht nur spreche in der
abstimmung sieg der extremen gegen den
willen des spitzenduos das ifw hält
herren ohne genügend eigene truppen
schlacht und schlacht abstimmung
abstimmung verliert kopiert gedemütigt
vom heckflügel der seine macht
demonstriert trotz der warnung dass
wir gerade beginnen und seinen eigenen
bundesvorstand den wir gerade gesehen
haben durch diesen antrag durch sage es
so deutlich zu demontieren wenn wir das
politikfähigkeit und in zukunft nennen
dann sind wir bereits heute schon wieder
in der vergangenheit waren gelandet also
ich beantrage ende dieses parteitag ist
dass es unwürdig und wir demontieren uns
hier gerade ein radikaler neuer vorstand
geführt von schwachen vorsitzenden
vorgeführt und zerpflückt von tag eins
an die afg heute sich und legt endgültig
ihr extrem rechtes inneres frei